behind me is the Royal London
homeopathic hospital and I'm here
because it's been an interesting week
for alternative medicine in Britain this
week no lemons television star and
promoter of midnight is fever dream mr.
blobby endorsed something called the EMP
pad it's a yoga mat and its inventors
claim that it's very low intensity
electromagnetic fields help cells in the
body function now I'm not going to go
into the loads of detail about the
evidence for the pad I'm very skeptical
but there are early studies that say
carefully applied specific
electromagnetic fields may actually do
some good I know I was surprised too and
okay a yoga mat probably isn't gonna
work like that but there are devices
using AM fields that are working well
enough that insurers are starting to pay
for them
I'll also skip over the insulting
reaction that no Ivan's got some people
on Twitter particularly if we told
someone suffering from cancer that it
might be because of their negative
attitude instead let's look at the
reaction of the folks who make the EMP
pad because okay the skeptics won't like
them whatever they do but there are
plenty of alternative medicine believers
out there surely the company would
welcome a celebrity endorsement you know
at the top of their website in big
letters they disavowed no led1 statement
entirely nothing to do with us they said
and the reason was he claimed they could
help cure cancer now across Europe
advertising prescription drugs and
medical treatments to the public is
banned they can advertise to doctors
sure but those American drug adverts
with a list of side effects just don't
happen here serious sometimes fatal
events such as infections lymphoma or
other types of cancer have habit blood
liver and nervous system problems
serious allergic reactions and new or
worsening heart failure have occurred
but in Britain there are even stricter
laws about cancer treatments you can't
get away with saying oh it's not really
a medical device or oh it's just some
herbs if you sell something to the
public saying it can help or cure cancer
you can be prosecuted even if it does
cure cancer the idea back in 1939 when
the law was passed still holds true
today sell your cure to doctors if you
give them an alternative medicine that
works with enough evidence to convince
them they'll start prescribing it and
you Plus do discover that you're
probably in line for Nobel Prize and if
they don't start prescribe
well it probably doesn't cure cancer
does it if you sell your cure directly
to the public it's almost certainly not
a cure and it's probably going to hurt
people that would otherwise go to the
doctor with this law no one has to prove
that your cure doesn't work they just
have to prove that you're selling it
without going through someone qualified
no Lloyd Mintz was in the clear when he
said this cures cancer
I think he's irresponsible but he can
believe that and he's not selling any
yoga mats himself I then had my tumor
destroyed by sound waves proving yet
again that energy is at the heart of
this issue but the folks who do sell
them they need to shut down that claim
right away or risk an investigation that
they would really want to avoid